[Music]
i rise
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to our coverage
of the protest in front of the supreme
court in washington dc
after scotus
and their decision on dobbs has
overturned roe v wade
there's protests there's counter
protests going on we wanted to bring you
live coverage
here at 4
eastern
we have some commentators for you today
uh we have a panel of guests waiting in
the wings to
comment on not just the protest but also
the decision and then some of the
trigger laws that have also
taken effect in some red states across
the country and how quickly republicans
jumped on taking away
women's rights
to their bodily autonomy
the first guest i want to bring in is
dina doll dina is an attorney and
legal analyst dina how are you
i'm great i thank you so much for having
me i'm actually here at disneyland with
my kids and you know what the fact that
my daughter is going to have less of
rights than me i just wanted to come and
talk so thanks for having me
absolutely absolutely so watching in the
last few months because we know we
we knew this was going to happen from
the leak coming from the supreme court
but what was your feeling uh like the
other day when this this decision
finally came down
you know as it's actually shocking both
as a lawyer and as a woman one for going
back 50 years you just it's hard to
imagine even though we knew it was
coming but from a legal point of view
reading the decision and really the
the twisted knots they went through in
order to do this basically saying we do
not have bodily autonomy because
potential life is involved not life but
potential life and that should really
scare every man and woman in this
country who does not want government
interference with their body
you know i i think um that
when we talk about some of these trigger
laws because i know in my state missouri
was first up to bat and i know you you
look at this from the illegal periscope
so tell us a little bit about that
trigger law and what you thought about
some of these states jumping on it
within six to ten minutes they were
already enacting these trigger loads i
know our governor and a.g were the
reports where they were in rooms all day
not just to enact those trigger laws but
to see how far they can push this
decision and how far they can actually
take this because we've seen the
president even say look you have to make
sure that women have the right to travel
even which is kind of worrisome what's
your thoughts on that yeah absolutely
states are you know oklahoma is already
having it at basically
fertilization
um you are not allowed to have an
abortion which you know we know the next
step is going to restrict a woman's
right and maybe a men's right to use
contraceptive i think oklahoma's trigger
law already probably goes there and then
we do see democratic states trying to
pass laws that would limit any liability
for a woman to travel to those states so
all the states here are scrambling you
know in the in the midst of all the bad
news there's actually one that i really
liked reading about which was the bite
administration with the fda is trying to
put in the regulations that the
ingredient used in the birth control i
mean abortion pill that women can
receive by mail
making that legal and having that
federal law supersede state laws that's
going to be really interesting to see
how that ends up playing out
yeah i think i think you bring up some
really good points there because
i mean when this decision came down i
was i was talking to my mother and and
of course she's very disappointed
because her granddaughter
doesn't get to receive the the rights
that she's been able to have and and my
wife has been able to have and i and she
said what do you think happens and i
said why i i think it's we just don't
know we don't know what they're going to
do we don't know how far they're going
to push it and some states are going to
be different than others um so it's it's
very up in the air i want to bring in
some a political commentator um why we
have them on hand here dina with you uh
emma silverman is in texas uh emma how
are you
um i could be better but
yes yes
so so tell us about some of those um
from a political standpoint because i
know you talk about the politics on tick
tock emma is a a very big tick tock so
is dina so we have two big tick tockers
here so tell us tell us about what your
political um you know what what do you
think about the political ramifications
could you speak to the politics a lot on
this
yeah so i think that this this has been
something that's
been in the works for a while been on uh
the gop agenda for a long time
and
even though it was released
as a leak a few months ago it was still
just so shocking to see
because as as
radical as that agenda gets sometimes
you you start you
almost don't think it's
it's possible that they could get away
with something like that uh considering
that justices lied under oath
at the time obviously
it's i guess people didn't think they
were lying but i think that this just
shows
it's
to them it's more of a game of what can
i lie about and what can i get away with
and it's been that way for a long time i
think it's just this is like
this is the peak and it's not it's not a
peak it's or it's not v peak it's a peak
and it's from here it terrifies me
because
their agenda gets scarier and scarier
especially in texas and these other
states every day
dina can you can you speak on um women
being terrified because i know the legal
ramifications in some of these states i
mean states like missouri are saying hey
it's going to be a felony if you go to
another they're trying to pass laws
where they're saying hey it's going to
be a felony if you if you travel to
another state
and might just touch you know we're
airing from the minus touch network here
the midas media network and they even
put out a video that shows that women
would be given pregnancy tests crossing
a state line and at first people like oh
that is that is outrageous how how would
you even dream but here we are a day
after this has happened and
they're probably considering this in
rooms full of men republican men right
now um can you tell us about some of
those what does it mean for women if
you're going to be a felon if you cross
a line to have a medical procedure this
sounds ridiculous but is this really our
reality
you know i would say yes only because of
the supreme court we have i mean
obviously there's some legal issues
about whether or not you're going to
cross state lines there's interstate
common commerce involved
but let's say it goes up to the supreme
court is that supreme court going to you
know rule in favor of the state who
wants to demand
no abortion probably so i think we are
entering kind of this new frontier where
we think the supreme court may be more
logical they really aren't and i would
really emphasize i mean obviously as a
woman i 100 percent makes me feel like a
second-class citizen but this you know
men should be scared about this too
because they're not just preventing an
uh an operation they are making a woman
have something done to their bodies
being pregnant for nine months i don't
see what the difference is you know
conservatives were really upset about
vaccines right like if you go into a
restaurant it's a vaccine which they can
do because there's no constitutional
right to go into a restaurant i don't
see why now states couldn't mandate
vaccines just like force you to do it
regardless because you're protecting
potential life the supreme court just
said bodily autonomy does not exist with
potential life we are in a new stage
where government interference over our
bodies should scare every man and woman
in this country
i think you're right because i i've said
on my show
we are live every monday through friday
and i've been saying it and pounding and
pounding that
eventually some of these trumped-up
white guys that are cheering this and
saying really vile stuff on the internet
are going to walk into a gas station and
ask the clerk where are the condoms and
they're going to say there are no
condoms we ban those condoms and so i
think we're gonna get to positions there
where a lot of people who are cheering
this don't even understand how this will
affect them
personally them or their families or
their friends they're not really
thinking of this
in a way of policy they're thinking of
in a way of
a political win and this really comes to
the heart of a policy and how women can
receive
safe health care i mean that's that's
really you know trying to get that at
the heart of it dean i know you have to
i know you have to go but tell us tell
us your your um hit your your handles
there your social handles so everyone
can find you yes thank you so much for
letting me just speak about this because
this is all hands on deck situation they
can find me on ask deena doll on tick
tock twitter instagram and dina doll on
youtube thanks so much for letting us
you know
get the word out well thank you thank
you dina for joining us i want to bring
in another attorney kimberly casper
thank you dina for joining us have a
great day and have fun there at
disneyland i want to bring in kimberly
casper and i also want to bring in
another political commentator lee
mcgowan politics girl lee how are you
yeah you're mike there kimberly you're
uh how are you
check check one two are we all there
check check one two yes kimberly yes
kimberly i can hear you lee are you are
you there
you know you are here we just can't hear
you i'm gonna go to kimberly first uh
lee give me a thumbs up when you have
your when you have you think you have
your mic set there just go to the
settings the little gear down there
kimberly um what do you think is the
legal standpoint when you have when when
you have this situation of
of the trigger laws and then this
question of contraception and
i mean are we going to get to a point to
where we can expect the government be
forcing to give women pregnancy tests
for travel or if they come into a state
or from a state or
you know
what can we expect from this do you
think
you know i am
i am just so upset with the current
state
i i feel like we're living in a twilight
zone
and there's so much distrust
um i think that started with george
floyd covid now it's coming into
abortion and gun rights um
just this past week
um and i think everybody has seen those
popular
memes and photos of all the justices who
just came in like amy and uh kavanaugh
and everyone who said that they would
had no intention of overturning roe v
wade and here we are
um so with
roe v wade now overturned them saying
that oh our right to travel is protected
i i
very much distrust that and
thinking that they would have pregnancy
tests at a border i put nothing past
anyone at this point
um
it's upsetting and i think what dina was
saying before there's going to be a lot
of preemption issues about uh
about the federal government passing
laws so states can't and
with the supreme court
making this move it's like what are we
actually doing here we're
we're not
unifying anybody by this decision we're
we're separating essentially all these
states into
into different countries basically with
their own laws and rules and and
decisions with the supreme court is
supposed to unify everybody and
it's
common sense now that
abortions are still gonna happen
they're going to happen it's just making
them not safe
um
and bringing people into different
states
are we gonna have to go and pay for fake
pregnancy tests
like fake covet tests when people want
to go and travel to greece and for their
vacations it's just
making that bigger gap between who
who has privilege and who doesn't yep i
i think you're right
lee i think you got your microphone
there uh uh good afternoon lee how are
you hi can you hear me now perfect
perfect okay and welcome welcome so i i
actually i want to ask i want to ask you
a question
because kimberly was kind of touching on
the
the legal part of it and kimberly i want
to ask you about the litigation here in
a second but lee on the politics of it
because we watched the supreme court
give a decision on handguns in new the
the state of new york where they said
the state doesn't have the right
to regulate a gun and then the very next
day this court
in a total flip-flop says the state has
the absolute right to tell a woman what
she can and cannot do with her body what
do you what do you make of that i mean
this does not seem like good politics
but
i i know
you dive deep into the politics on your
show so tell us what you think of those
politics of those two decisions back to
back what do you
what what do you make of this well those
two decisions back to back the argument
would be guns are in the constitution
and abortion is not right that's that's
what they're gonna say um but the
concept of the supreme court in general
the concept is that the power of the
court comes from the idea that they're
above politics you know we're supposed
to believe that
if you are a justice or a judge you're
following an established set of rules
that the law itself is its own thing and
the justices are simply there to
interpret it they're not supposed to be
political our entire legal system is
based on something that is way bigger
than a justice's personal preference and
that's why they have to be vetted so so
sincerely when they're going into these
jobs and they have to be confirmed by
the senate and they have to have all
these things because it's such an
insanely consequential job that affects
the entire country so this implication
that you can have settled law for five
decades where the facts remain entirely
the same right we haven't row and casey
relitigated this we've relitigated roe
multiple times over the past almost 50
years and the courts have always come to
the same conclusion that the women of
america have this constitutional right
to make a private decision or whether or
not to terminate a pregnancy now the
science hasn't changed pregnancy hasn't
changed the burden on the potential
mother hasn't changed women's rights
theoretically uh equal to men's rights
so the only thing that has changed since
this was originally decided in 1973 and
then all the subsequent attacks on it
since then is the makeup of the court
itself the actual justices right that's
the only difference and the fact is that
the sponsors of the bill in mississippi
um that brought this case dobbs um has
said that they only brought it because
there were new justices so they weren't
there to argue a new case they were
there to get a new result and i think
that is the problem because that calls
into legitimacy it's a legitimacy
problem for the court itself if you can
get a different result just with
different justices then we're not really
dealing with the law we're dealing with
a personal preference of individual
people
yeah i i think
you know this makeup of the supreme
court and that's one of the issues that
people are bringing up because emma what
do you make of this
of
it the majority of these justices who
made this decision
were not were not appointed by
presidents who got the popular vote
that's another
case that people are trying to make
today at these protests as they stand to
defend women's rights and there are
counter protests as well but what do you
what do you make of
like lee saying the makeup and
how the minority rule type thing is
happening and then i want to go to
kimberly back for the litigation what do
you make of it
i think that
it's clear that there was motive to put
these specific justices and they were
carefully chosen they had
they had their opinions far ahead of
time it was not news that
it was they were going to make some of
these decisions i think that seeing
the road decision
was just the first of many surreal
decisions to come from them they and
i'm absolutely 100 for term limits and i
think that i
forget which senator i think or house
member which representative is
introducing a bill
to
call for term limits on supreme court
justices because
it's
alarming that there are nine people
that nobody voted for and
a lot of the presidents who appointed
them
lost the popular vote like you said it's
just so alarming to
learn and i think it's a big reason why
a bunch of the youth
doesn't learn about
government very much because it's a very
like condescending topic it's very
complicated because you're learning
about the supreme court you're learning
that nine people
that nobody voted for are making these
insanely detrimental decisions that
affect
millions and millions of people
and it's just
there's something that can there's a lot
that can be done and no one's doing
enough about it
i agree we're getting our feedback here
um kimberly tell me about the because
you're a litigator so tell me about the
litigation that we're possibly going to
see
when when women actually get the chance
to challenge this because i know they
will in these states where they're
they're really pushing on these trigger
laws so what do you think what do you
see from that litigation standpoint of
if women are going to
have the chance to have their day in
court as it were
obviously working up the supreme court
is
not always
um fanciful in this situation because of
what leonema pointed out that this
supreme court is the makeup of the
supreme court at this point what do you
make of some of this litigation do you
think this will stop some of these
trigger laws or do you think that's just
just pure fantasy
well
i think to
i think the problem with
with this ban on abortion now and these
trigger laws starting it it sets us back
to the 50 years before roe v wade was
was put in place women are going to be
scared they're not going to want to come
forward
the criminal implications that are going
to come from it it's going to
shrink women back who's going to want to
stand up
after this decision at the supreme court
has been made
to say that they were wrong um
i know
especially during uh
covid and
with people trying to
i know especially during code with
people trying to say uh that
the masked mandates and everything um
were wrong and shouldn't be happening
it's it's just very hard it's a david
versus goliath sort of situation
um and i also
think what would be interesting to see
with the criminalization of it
is what implication does that have on
first amendment rights to our freedom of
speech now
with
i think
especially the younger generation who
still the decision to have kids is still
there
i believe we're going to be posting
videos of
do we have to go to posting videos of
how to have safe abortions now are we
going to
uh protect people and get them to travel
safely to other states
uh to those safe haven states what
what's the criminalization gonna be like
now is
our
states that um
that are criminalizing it and
criminalizing um
aiding and abetting are they going to
block
videos block uh
podcasts and social media talking about
safe abortions and
talking about these safe haven states
it's
i just think it just opens up a lot more
that we have yet to see
i i think you're right because joe
biden's speech the other day when he
gave his statement which was about uh
it's about 20 minutes um he kind of went
to this he was like look you cannot stop
the mail you cannot stop travel and we
the department of justice will fight as
long as he's the president as long as
he's uh in the executive branch um he
will fight for those rights that he can
fight for at this point i mean there's
not a lot that the president united
states can say about this decision that
the supreme court has made just because
of our three branches of government here
but he definitely can defend the rights
that are still on the books as long as
they are still in the books but i think
that's why it's so important
that we pay attention here and i want to
go back to the feed here now you see
everyone gathering here in front of the
supreme court um it's been a show
throughout the country i i want to bring
in another lawyer and another political
commentator she's coming in of her own
here on the broadcast at midas media
network jessica denson and karen
agnibolo
of legal af karen
and jessica how are you
all right good to see you
okay good to see you
um so
karen can you speak to the
um
can you speak to
the legal part of this thing i see her i
see your cat there wants to get in on
the act i know i'm really sorry no it's
okay
oh see jessica jessica and karen brought
their cats today that's perfect that's
perfect so tell us what you think about
some of this legal talk around the
litigation and
and what's going to happen and what it
means for women because it's really kind
of a weird
thought process that if you cross an
imaginary line you're no longer a second
class citizen and you go back over that
imaginary line now you're a second-class
citizen again i mean really
in this country it's going to be a weird
situation that we have i believe that's
why they're not going to stop at
roe v wade they're going to try to go at
women's bodily autonomy even in these
quote unquote blue states where there is
the protected right of abortion and
bodily autonomy what do you make of it
karen i go to you
uh maybe maybe her cat locked up her her
screen there uh jessica i'll go to you
yeah first of all i mean we've i've
heard this mentioned in the in the
discussion already
obviously this is just such sheer
hypocrisy on on these purists these
fundamentalists these uh forced birth
anti-abortion um movement individuals
because as we all know abortions are not
going to stop this is just going to make
them more dangerous and more deadly rich
republican men and their wives and their
mistresses are always going to have
access to abortion if and when they when
they want it and believe me they want it
they will be continuing to have access
as they need to abortions and it's just
the the people that need it most who are
not going to have
that access and as we're talking about
this we're talking about the
possible infringement of other very
fundamental rights that that are very
likely coming from this extremist
illegitimate supreme court and as we're
thinking about this can we just as can
we resolve to
not anymore continue to let these
republicans these fascists hijack the
freedom platform these people are the
most anti-freedom anti-human rights
individuals um
i'm reading i have this book here that
there's this article that i love to read
it's it's kind of a very inspirational
article for me it happens to be from
1895. it's called the new woman and and
i'm going to read you a little a little
excerpt from it it's talking about
when in olden times olden times to 1895
okay women were treated as chattel right
as property which is essentially what
the supreme court has done in this
decision and it says
the date this is 1895. the date is no
longer bc
might no longer makes right and in this
fair land at least fear has ceased to
kiss the iron heel of wrong
why then should we continue to demand
woman's love and woman's help while we
recklessly promise as lover and
candidate what we never fulfill as
husband and office holder
1895
25 years before women's suffrage and
here we are in 2020 with these
these extremists
right-wing illegitimate
supreme court justices
setting woman back
to
this time i mean
please let us let us keep this outrage
let us not let the the media you know
put us onto some other track where we're
worried about temporary inflation and we
let that drive the narrative in november
this could not be more serious we have
to be energized we have to be mobilized
and
my god
make sure that these people do not
remain in power and we have the tools
that we need which is going to take us
voting like hell to make sure these
people are not in powers in legislatures
and not in power in our congress so we
can cut a firo and if if we get the the
appropriate energy in this direction
expand this court so it is no longer
packed by these right-wing extremists
well i appreciate the fire there you
know that i always
like like the heat because i think you
have to come i think you have to come at
these people with that same energy that
they try to come at this because they're
not going to stop i mean i mean this
isn't like they're like oh
we overturned roe v wade so now it's
we're good we're good we're just gonna
lay down our arms and walk away um karen
i see i see your cat got your your mic
working back there so
tell us tell us what you'd make of all
of of the news over the week
um but also seeing these protests today
what hope does that give you i know
jessica is saying we need to get in the
streets so and emma and leah lee as well
so what do you think
i mean to me this is
some of the darkest weeks in our
nation's history and
the fact that we've had uh several
decisions by the supreme court but then
culminating in this dobbs versus jackson
women health overturning rovers this way
it's just staggering and shocking and
you know yes it was not shot we didn't
we did know it was coming but just the
scope and breadth of this decision you
know most supreme court decisions really
just decide the issue at hand and had
they done this had they done that here
they would have just decided whether or
not the
law in
mississippi
banned abortion after 15 weeks was
constitutional and that's really what
normally if they had done things
normally
a supreme court justice would do they
would just rule on that one law but they
took it further and overturned roe and
casey in all of the cases that have
established a woman's right to bodily
autonomy and abortion for the last 50
years
and
did a sweeping sweeping decision for the
first time in our nation's history
the supreme court took away a right that
was firmly established
and uh you know i used to be one of
those people who thought that a lot of
the um
you know people on the left were kind of
alarmists and hysterical and now i've
come to believe that we are they were
not at all they were just prescient and
we we should be very very afraid and you
know the majority of opinion said this
only applies to abortion by the way it
doesn't apply to anything else um
however uh justice thomas who i think is
probably one of the most dangerous
people in this country right now he
wrote a concurring opinion where he
invited not not like a dog whistle sort
of quiet kind of hinting he actually
called out and invited
uh lawyers on the right to bring
challenges
to
the uh right to the cases that establish
a right to contraception a right to gay
marriage a right to con to consensual
sexual relations i mean it's
unbelievable to me that these are the
rights that the supreme court is going
to rule on next and that we are going to
start losing one by one by one it is
outrageous what's happening and the
other thing i want to say
is every there were there's a majority
opinion there was three concurrent two
or three concurring opinions and a and a
dissenting opinion every one of them was
written by a man including the descent
which actually kind of pissed me off you
know that they had
breyer um and
you know sotomayor and kagan you know
i'm so sick of these men uh legislating
and opining on women's rights and
women's bodies and i really
every single one of those decisions was
written by a man and i just want to end
with one other thought which is you know
the
the decision very much talked about how
you know the word abortion
and frankly the word woman isn't in
there either um and that's because when
at the time the constitution was written
in the 1700s and when the amendments
were ratified in the 1800s guess who did
it was all men women were second-class
citizens didn't have the right to vote
didn't have any rights weren't citizens
you know weren't actual citizens and so
they went back down you know the
majority opinion said there's nothing in
this nation's history that establishes a
right to abortion nothing in the
constitution that talks about it there's
nothing in the history that establishes
it so you know therefore it doesn't
apply well guess why it's because that's
the history that was um when when men
were the only sort of white men actually
were the only people who were considered
humans and considered uh to have
rights and that's why it wasn't talked
about and why it wasn't there and they
just totally threw out the window the
last 50 years of history that every
single woman who would have an abortion
or get pregnant today has had a right to
since the day they were born i mean it
doesn't apply to me you know i'm no
longer of age you know this applies to
every single woman who this is going to
apply to every day of their life
they had a right to bodily autonomy
until friday and so it's just outrageous
what's happening and we have to women
have to take to the streets everybody
has to take to the streets they have to
end the filibuster i again i was against
ending the filibuster i was against
expanding the supreme court forget about
it it's now a matter of life or death
and it's not being alarmist they have to
do that and they have to fix this
because we are headed down a scary scary
path
yeah
sorry about that lee i see you shaking
your head and i i can tell that you had
a lot of commentary um so what what what
are some of your thoughts there on some
of the things that karen was bringing up
well i mean karen's exactly right so is
uh jessica so is so are all the women on
this i mean
this is not
going to stop i mean i think you've
heard a lot of women say that this is
terrifying because it is terrifying um
it's quite clear that
one party has spent 40 years planning
this they have been unhappy basically
for a hundred years um but particularly
since civil rights and women's rights
really took off and they're not going to
stop here at taking rights away from
women they're just they don't like this
multicultural pluralistic democracy
right it's just not working for them
they know they can't win
honestly in this world because they
can't get enough votes because they
don't have enough good ideas that people
like so they withhold our votes they
suppress our votes they gerrymander our
votes because they're trying to take us
back to a time where
it was more hegemonic where it was white
great you know white straight christian
men and the patriarchy was in charge and
all the rest of us kind of took the
scraps we were given and we've got
ourselves to a position now where women
have a voice uh people of color have a
voice indigenous people have a voice
we're all speaking up and that doesn't
serve them and
i i think
the word terrifying is is very useful
because
this
this is like it's a snowball effect and
when you're talking about what we can do
about it there it it's you feel a little
bit helpless because there really only
is a couple things we can do about it
and it's voting um and i know that emma
was talking about term limits and how
someone was coming up with a bill uh for
term limits and unfortunately i don't
think that's ever gonna work because a
lifetime appointment is in the
constitution it's written there so
that's going to be a really hard thing
to overturn not to mention that case
that law would get kicked to the supreme
court and i don't think the supreme
court is going to limit their own power
what isn't in the constitution is the
amount of justices that can be on the
court we've had a fluctuating amount of
justices for years people think it has
to be nine but it doesn't have to be
nine we've just had it be nine for a
long time when it was made nine it was
because we had nine federal court
districts uh in the country now we have
13 federal court districts so it makes
sense that we would expand the court at
least from 9 to 13. um
personally i would love to see it that
we expand the court there's nothing
against that in the constitution but
that has to be a law it has to be a law
that congress writes and the senate
passes and the president signs it has to
go through congress congress is the
check
on the supreme court because the supreme
court has been set up that they check
themselves they have to decide if they
step down from a case they have to
decide and they're not going to clarence
thomas isn't taking himself off 1-6
cases because he just wants to he won't
and there's nothing to check him so the
only thing that will check him is
congress and congress could expand the
court we can't do anything about the
lifetime appointment it's written in the
constitution unless we have a
constitutional amendment that's not
happening but what we can do is expand
it personally i would love to see
12 justices 13 justices let's say 13
justices but we have nine on the court
at a time so the
supreme court justices rotate in so you
don't know which justice you're gonna
get you can't say oh i've got six votes
in the bag for this this case i'm
bringing i don't know which nine
justices i'm gonna get there's a whole
ex idea that we have 27 justices and
they wrote in two two straight courts of
nine justices at a time and our supreme
court sits there and you don't know
which justices you're gonna get you
don't know which justices you're gonna
work with you have a certain amount of
justices and they rotate in we we'd hear
more cases it would be faster um and you
wouldn't be able to guarantee yourself
an outcome which is where we get the
legitimacy problem of the court itself
if i can guarantee myself an outcome the
mississippi dobbs people were like i can
guarantee myself an outcome as soon as
amy coney parrot was put on that court i
know exactly what they're going to say
that's not justice that's politics and
if it's politics and i know the way
you're going to vote then why why are
you sitting there in a lifetime
appointment right why do you have a
lifetime appointment
and i can't do anything about you
sitting there that makes no sense so i
would like to see an expansion of the
courts it's not packing the court it's
expanding the court to make justice
actually blind again to make it fair
well and to take politics out of it i
think it shouldn't be there there should
be no politics right well and even if
there is politics there what you're
saying is when you draw those trolls you
don't know what politics you're actually
going to get emma i want to go to you
because i know you i know you have to go
here soon in just a few minutes so tell
us what you think of this expanding the
court and i really uh tell us about your
video because i i noticed a video that
midas touch posted that you were talking
about this decision in the other day so
talk about expanding in your video that
you had
yeah um so i completely agree with
expanding uh
i think that i and i completely agree
about the constitutionality of it all
uh i think that
it's
it's hard because everyone talks about
it all the time everyone talks about
ending the filibuster and expanding the
court it's it's been a topic of
conversation it's been mentioned by
many politicians in both the house
but no one's doing it
and
i think
like the most fresh part
[Music]
it's
it's
my future it's my gen my generation of
women's future
it's
the generation above me a new generation
below me it's our future and watching
power hungry
people in that court
playing the game of politics
that affects
our my future our future everyone i
know's future is just
it makes you feel so powerless and
there's
there's nothing there's no real answer
besides expanding the court at this
point because i i
i don't know how we can let those
justices those illegitimate power-hungry
justices sit on that court and make
decisions about our future when none of
us elected them none of us voted for
them
and it's
i i completely agree with expanding the
court um and to touch on my video a
little bit i
i was just talking to um ben that
morning i just
read the decision uh instantly
shut my laptop and everything
um and ben asked me to make a video
about a five to seven minute video just
speaking my mind
and that's what i did i set up my phone
and i spoke and it felt really good to
speak and the video
is
just everything that i could have wanted
from
what i what i sent to them in my voice
and i'm so thankful that i'm able to
have my voice heard and
but just to touch on i think one of the
most important parts of that video
is that
it's it used to be hard to argue that
this
that overturning roe v wade and being
anti-choice was about controlling women
it used to be a it was clear but it was
hard to argue
but now it's easy
it's it's very clear that it is entirely
about controlling women it's it's not
about states rights
it's it's because it's not about small
government it's just not it's a branch
of government
telling
other governments that they can tell
women
what to do with their bodies and it's
not about children
as we've seen from recent mass shootings
and
lack gun control and horrible rulings
on on gun control and concealed carry
and open carry it's not about children
at all
and it's not about life
well
emma give us give us where people can
find you on tick tock twitter and
instagram i i believe you're on all the
social media tell us tell us where they
can find you and your great videos i've
been following you for quite some time
so tell us where we can find all those
videos about the uh the opinions that
you have
well thank you so much um yes i'm on
tick tock it is emma underscore
silverman one
and i'm on twitter emma silverman one
well great emma thank thank you for
thank you for joining the panel here um
we we really appreciate having you here
i i know everyone everyone loves your
videos here there's no doubt that they
they love your videos so thank you very
much emma we'll talk to you very soon i
want to bring in another another
political commentator she's she's on
twitter you and she's joining us by
phone uh jojo from jurors uh jojo are
you there
i'm i'm here can you hear me okay i
can't i can hear you fine um i want to
go to you and then back to the panel
here i know you only have a few minutes
because you're on the phone but
everyone leans on you a little bit on
twitter about your opinions because of
your writing and you're
you're you're a reply guy as you say so
tell us tell us what your reply is um to
this decision but also
does it give you confidence to see these
people marching in the streets i i i
felt a lot of confidence this morning
when i started to watch these protests
happen and see these videos posted on
social media and it gave me confidence
and that's why i wanted to use because i
usually do a best of the week where it's
pre-recorded here on this hour um every
saturday but i wanted to use this to
highlight the protest but to highlight
women's voices
was important so
tell us what you find
about some of these things on social
media about the protests and stuff give
us your opinion
well
after the election in 2016 a lot of us
took to the streets um and protested
peacefully i myself uh went to new york
city and then i went to morristown new
jersey the following year um and it was
incredibly inspiring to see how many men
and women and children understood
the power of our voice because things
felt pretty hopeless
for a lot of us after that election i
think i can probably safely speak for a
lot of people
and being able to put action
uh
out there to say my voice is actually
much more powerful than you know the
people in charge right now um that kind
of activism that kind of energy uh that
kind of ground swell that that actually
can make make change i believe that i
truly do and i believe what we're seeing
right now um is is the same kind of
energy i think
that the republicans made a huge [ __ ]
mistake with this um because
i think if there's anything that is
going to energize men and women um in
the democratic party and independence
too um this is one of those issues that
is going to do that i mean we need to
stay angry i really believe we need to
stay fired up we cannot let this
momentum uh lapse we can't let it be
another school shooting that it's not
being talked about two weeks later this
has to fuel our fire because to lee's
point which i think is magnificent about
rotating 27 justices that would be
fantastic so that you don't get this
locked and loaded decision
um in order for us to be able to achieve
that we need to see change in in
congress right in order for that to
happen we need to [ __ ] vote i hope i
can't say [ __ ] tony on here um
because oh absolutely you can you're
you're here on the midas network and
you're with the tony michael so you can
say almost any word that you'd like so
go ahead
because i do i tend to swear a lot but
like that's what we need to do we need
to vote like we have never [ __ ] voted
in our lives not not even in 2020 we
need to get to the polls we need to vote
blue we need to vote on our state
legislatures we need to make change so
that we can get expand the court and and
so that we can codify roe um it's not
impossible there are ways to do it we
just have to be fired up like i think we
are right now and
um
to emma's point about this not being
about children i mean it absolutely the
hypocrisy of this is utterly astounding
i mean that's what republicans do best
is hypocrisy but i mean that this is a
party that is against universal health
care and universal childco they're
against paid family and medical leave we
have one of the highest rates of
maternal mortality among all the rich
nations in the world this isn't at all
about children it's not about life it's
about power power that they're trying to
harness right now because it is slipping
through their fingers because the
electorate is is is not in their favor
and so they're going to do whatever they
can to seize as much power as possible
right now and it's not going to stop so
like just i just wanted to speak to
those two points but we need to be fired
up like we've never been fired up before
well thank you joe for joining us i know
you had to join us by phone today
because you uh you were you were having
some pool fun with the children um
i appreciate you giving us a few minutes
of your time everyone appreciate
appreciate your commentary uh don't
don't give up there on on twitter and
get out there and protest protest
protest and vote vote vote and use your
voice i know you will joe so so thanks
thanks for joining us thank you very
much we'll talk we'll talk to you soon
my friend okay talk soon bye-bye
so
i want to go back to kimberly for a
second um kimberly
you know she was talking about mortality
lates and and children and we've been
mentioning children and
we've kind of forgotten that right that
they always say save the children save
the children save the children um but
there's situations
where
you would expect a woman a woman to have
a legal right where
she may have a type of pregnancy that
terminates on its own and for her to
actually to have another child she may
have to have a medical procedure
not only just to save her life but to
save her ability to have another child
so sometimes these quote unquote
abortion services
aren't just to terminate a pregnancy but
it's to
extend life beyond that terminated
pregnancy for whatever reason it may be
i mean i know women personally who have
had procedures
who if not for that procedure they would
have not had a child or more children so
what do you think some of that you know
being a litigator where do you think
some of that comes in the karen's dog's
got an opinion here apparently but let's
go to kimberly first
um
when this decision came out
i have never felt more physically
violated by
people who i have never met and don't
know
um
and i think for somebody to
say what i can and can't do for my own
health
um
it it isn't
it isn't um
a celebration it isn't life-winning
it
i i think it goes back to people
pushing their own it goes back to the
supreme court justices pushing their own
beliefs on
us and
i
i i was raised catholic my dad is one of
eight and my mom is one of seven
children
um
they raised me not that i can do
whatever i want with my body um
there
to push
your own beliefs on other people
um
i
i that shouldn't be law and that that
that shouldn't be the supreme court's
opinion on that um
and
there's going
to be
different decisions that come down like
what actually is abortion with
contraception there are different
opinions about iuds being a type of
abortion different types of hormones in
in contraceptives being abortion so
there's
there's going to be a lot of trouble
with that there's
egg fertilizations what is is that going
to be a fetus when it's fertilized um
there's going to be a lot of developing
law on that but
i i think when the constitution was
written
back then it was a lot of religion based
and women didn't talk about their bodies
back then
men didn't know anything about women's
bodies and the fact that we
can
talk about it now and how
the mortality rates and
just physically how it affects our
bodies now to be silenced on now to have
it be criminalized
it's just setting us back and it's not
even 50 years every like i understand
that it's
this sets us back 50 years it's more
than that it right not just the one day
that roe v wade came up and that's when
women's rights started it was a lot
it was many many many years before that
um
and so
it's just very upsetting here
jessica i want to go to you
on that point because you were shaking
your head that it was it's been it's
setting back more than 50 years so
what's your what's your thoughts on that
and
some of the commentary that we've had
here
yeah well um
along those same lines i've always been
a christian and i've always been
pro-choice i mean there is nothing in my
faith that says that uh
that
the government should have the right to
take a woman's god-given right to
determine her own salvation away from
her and i think that just goes back to
the hypocrisy of this decision
and like emma was saying the
power
that these people want to exert this
isn't this isn't about it's not about
children it's not about you know
stopping abortion it is about power
and if you don't already follow um
senator sheldon whitehouse or listen to
his speeches
i highly suggest that he he talks so
much and with so much detail about the
influence and dark money that has gone
into putting these justices on the
supreme court for a determined outcome
this is a a power initiative okay
and
this goes to the larger picture that we
are dealing with where this these
rulings that are being forced upon the
american people are so undemocratic they
so go against the grain
of we the people
against what most americans want for
as far as abortion rights as far as gun
safety
and
the supreme court is one extreme example
another extreme example is our senate we
right now have a 50 50 senate but i
remind people of this as much as i
possibly can the democrats in the senate
represent 40 million more americans than
their republican counterparts 40 million
more and yet they only have half the
seats
so this just this this
highlights this undemocratic um you know
these undemocratic forces that we have
going on right now
highlight the urgency of of putting more
democrats into power because the simple
fact of the matter is that democrats
represent
many
many more americans they are much more
representative of the actual desires of
of women and the majority of americans
on so many issues so we have to just
like everybody is saying keep this
energy keep it till november and make
sure that we turn out votes like we have
never turned them out before to to put
in place the people that actually
represent us
you always you always have a way of
putting an explanation point on it thank
you very much jessica i really
appreciate that i want to go to karen
because karen you're doing a special
episode um of legal af tonight with with
ben mizellis and michael popock uh i
believe it airs what time does it tell
us about when it airs and what you guys
are going to be talking about it will be
on the midas touch
youtube channel right here so click
subscribe while you're here and watch
that episode but tell us about that uh
episode tonight what you guys kind of
talk about and break down on the this
special episode of legally
yeah so on saturday nights uh it's
usually just popock and ben myself who
do
uh the legal af show but i joined i do
the midweek with kopak on wednesdays but
i joined them uh tonight for a special
episode just because this is such a
momentous uh week that's just kind of
unprecedented in our nation's history
it's at eight o'clock eastern which is
three hours from now on the midas
network and we talk mostly about this
about this issue and about this case and
we break down kind of what the issues
are
and the decision and what was new about
it and and kind of what this means for
the future
and what to look out for we also talk
about the uh kind of groundbreaking
second amendment gun
um gun licensing case uh uh that also
came down this week bruin we um there's
a church and state case we talked about
and we also recapped the jan's sixth
hearing so it's
just you know the the january sixth
hearings congressional hearings that are
going on are kind of
earth-shattering in and of themselves
and could require could be their own
special episode of legal af because
they're so important and so much is
coming out and the fact that that was
just you know 25 of the show because so
many other really important uh issues
had to be discussed from this week so we
all came together because it was such a
special week that it kind of called for
all hands on deck so join us in three
hours live i think it's it's a show that
is no not like any other show we've had
and it's a really important one and i
hope everyone's also watching the jan
six hearings um
you've been doing such a phenomenal job
at hosting tony and you've really done
such a great job bringing people
together and really helping lead
everyone through these various hearings
and what they mean and providing great
commentary so
uh thank you for having me on that as
well and having me on today and it's
just you know i'm honored to be here
with with all of these these um
wonderful women and with you and uh
thank you so much for having me and i'm
sorry about the dog and cat and other
interruptions but you know it's saturday
we're home and you know you just got to
do what you got to do
we're glad they joined in we're glad
they joined in so i know i know i caught
you off guard and i caught everyone off
guard today because we tried to put this
together so fast but i i felt that it
was important to hear your voice so
everyone go watch legal aff can i just
hear them can i say can i say we're
walking really quick sorry i don't mean
to interrupt um i i just think uh i
think something kimberly said is really
important about how you know we don't
know the reach of this decision and i
think that's the one thing the sobering
thing we all need to think about you
know
when you think about the fact that so
many women who experience
infertility issues or fertility issues
they do things like you know freeze
their eggs or they freeze embryos and
sometimes they decide to use them and
sometimes they don't what do you do then
you know what is what are these embryos
right and are these potential life and
what are the rights now and how are
these going to be legislated i mean it's
it's just one example of about 100 that
i think this is going to be winding its
way through the courts it's we have no
idea the far reach of this terrible
decision and what it's going to be and
how it's going to impact just the things
we've all learned to take for granted so
i just i just really wanted to punctuate
that because you know the the political
the things like like i love what lee was
saying about um have 27 justices and
rotate them in and out and truly make
justice blind you know i
actually think it's a brilliant idea you
know and there's so many great ideas
that you know people are talking about
from i really do i really love that idea
um but but again
it's be partly because we don't know uh
this is going to have tentacles and
reaches in ways that we just have no
idea how what this is going to impact
you know it's it's going to be um things
that we can't that we haven't even
thought of yet and you know especially
if it's just going to be this this
particular court as it is so it's it's
it's very very um frightening
yes well thank you karen for joining us
and everyone go join uh karen in three
hours at eight eastern on the midas
youtube channel for legal af as uh her
ben my zealous and michael popock break
down some of these decisions from the
supreme court but uh this dobbs decision
in particular lee i want to go to you as
we as we kind of close out here um
she kind of brought up your idea of the
the 27 justices and i think that's just
one brilliant idea and i want to tell
you i've been getting messages here
privately talking about the idea that
you just had so um everyone's everyone's
paying attention
so
but what do you make of some of these
ramifications because even even dina at
the beginning brought up a good one of
men don't even understand how this is
going to affect them because
and we we don't fully know
because we don't know what is going to
be negated how the state-to-state thing
works i mean tell us about give us
another really good idea you you floated
this 27 justices give us another really
good i know this is stuff i think about
at home i'm such a total nerd um
listen i think the bottom line is we
need to ask ourselves what control does
the government really have over us right
do we really believe that mitch
mcconnell and ron desantis and matt
gates or even
the justices like clarence thomas and
brett kavanaugh and amy coney barrett
truly have the final say in what we can
and cannot do with our own body right do
we believe that is that something that
we believe because speaking to jessica's
point
ultimately it's about power it's not
about all these other things it's about
power and i think that we have to think
who has power over us who is in charge
of our bodies um because people say well
it's not really gone abortion isn't gone
it's just been kicked to the states
right and i'm like yes but you can't
change people's
um
you can't change people's uh rights
based on what state you're in right
that's just not how it works that that
was literally the argument for slavery
just kick it back to the states let the
states decide but you can't have some
states hold people in bondage and some
states where people are free it's not a
state decision women either have rights
to their own body or they don't it's not
up for debate and quite frankly
we shouldn't even need a federal law
that says we have a right to our own
person because it should be a given um
i've i've always said to be quite honest
i am exhausted by the fact that women's
bodily autonomy has always been
connected to a court case right i'm i'm
i find that exhausting that we were
continually relitigating roe v wade and
the hypocrisy of the pro-life movement
and the court cases and the opinions and
the politicking around it a woman's
right to her own body should not be up
for debate
but if we don't have it anymore then we
shouldn't just be trying to pass a law
that sanctifies the right to abortion we
should be passing a law that sanctifies
the right to bodily autonomy let's just
step directly out of the baby murder
camp right
we can all agree that our bodies are our
own that you can't touch my body without
my permission right that abusing or
hurting out someone else is illegal we
can't even take organs from a dead body
right unless they agreed to that before
they died our bodies belong to us and
anything that suggests otherwise should
be against the law if i don't want to
carry a baby to term i shouldn't have to
because my womb belongs to me no one can
use it without my permission not even a
fetus right so if i want to have remove
a part of my body if i want to have a
nose job if i want to have top surgery
if i want to have a hysterectomy that
should be my choice and my choice alone
if i am dying of a degenerative disease
i should be able to choose to end my
life legally and on my own terms that
shouldn't be something i need permission
for we can't continue to pick and choose
who gets full autonomy over their body
and who does not so we need to decide
who makes these decisions is it the
government is it the courts is it the
church i think it should be individual
in this case we should reflect what we
want to do with our own body so if we go
back to what jessica was saying about
power
when people say just vote just vote
right
yes vote but don't think of it as one
vote think of it as gaining power right
expanding power holding on to power
because we need to get more pro-choice
pro-democracy people elected at every
level of government we need to defend
our rights um to our votes to our voice
to our bodies in the months and the
years ahead because we don't have a
choice now there's no choice we have to
unseat these anti-choice legislators and
we have to flip the chambers and we have
to stop these totalitarian bans and
whatever slippery slope we're on now
that clarence thomas is talking about um
we need to hold these republican
senators accountable for voting time and
time again against our health and our
safety and our democracy and we need to
do that at the state level the local
level and the federal level because we
need enough senators who will vote to
expand the courts because this one is
clearly bought and paid for right it is
a corrupt political arm of one party and
one fraction of a party that is seeking
a different america than the vast amount
of
americans want right so we need to
expand our power hold on to our power
and
we start that today not in november
today getting people registered to vote
firing people up staying fired up yes do
these protests absolutely but don't play
into this ridiculous you know what ted
cruz is saying that we're all going to
be so violent and horrible they were
making hilarious jokes last night they
were like someone kicked over a traffic
cone and everyone was like antifa you
know like we need to be really careful
because they're looking for us to be
violent so they can blame stuff on us
one
on fire uh
garbage can is is just fox news fodder
so we need to be smart about the way
we're doing this and we need to be smart
about what we're doing leading up to
november and then post november because
we've got to keep that house we've got
to expand that senate and we have to get
past that filibuster so we can actually
get laws that reflect the people past i
think the calm is important that you're
talking about in the streets i mean we
need to peacefully protest as as we see
the pictures here of people protesting
uh peacefully
and it's encouraging to see right but i
think you're right when you talk about
the ballot because i think our vote is
not just marking the ballot that you get
it's it's about engaging rather it be
whatever you're talented at i i know
you're talented at putting these ideas
and and recording them and then and then
cutting them into the great show the
award-winning show i see your award
behind you um
yeah i'll i'm gonna let you plug it here
in just a second but uh um but you you
do such a great job jessica does such a
great job with commentary i know
kimberly probably litigates the hell out
of these things and and we all have to
use our talents we all have to use the
things that we're good at i mean i yell
and scream into the microphone every
single day
but people out there listening
listen to what lee is saying it's not
just about marking that ballot it's
about getting engaged it's about walking
in the streets if you can protest it's
about making phone calls um for a
candidate rather a pro-democracy
candidate and and doing the things that
you need to do we i saw on social media
uh ben mizellis and jordy mizellis the
the midas touch two of the minus such
brothers went down to dallas and they
were they were writing note cards and
they were knocking on doors and and all
that matters it really does matter and
that's engaging that vote because again
it's not just about marking that ballot
it's about actually engaging in the
voting process and i think that's what
you're saying there lee um
i am but i also i want to speak to what
emma said because it made me so sad
because emma is far younger than i am
and she said i feel powerless
and i want to tell her and every other
young person
you are not powerless that is how they
want you to feel
and if our votes didn't count if our
power wasn't palpable they wouldn't be
trying to take them from us they
wouldn't be trying to take our power and
our votes and suppress us so much you're
not powerless they want you to feel that
way we can make a difference but we have
to do it in a short period of time
because if we give them much more power
it'll be impossible to roll back so now
is the time and i want every young
person to know that we are dependent on
them understanding that we are fighting
for their future just as much as we're
fighting for our present
well speaking of fighters and young
people jessica knows something about
fighting these these these wackaloons as
i call them sometimes um she fought the
trump campaign with the trump nda and so
give us give us um jessica give us your
thoughts on fighting back and knowing
that you have that power and just what
lisa if you didn't have it they wouldn't
be trying to take it
there you go that is the key isn't it
they know what we have so ah mentally i
i so
i i just echo everything she says yes
we have the power we have simply to
exercise it and yes
such a short amount of time to do this
you know this is kind of we are we are
viewing all these things through a
political lens um or a legal lens these
are really just kind of universal issues
when we do not handle situations in our
personal lives they come back to us and
when they come back to us they're
usually more severe the next time
they're they're increasingly more severe
until we handle them until we put our
foot down and say thus far and no
farther and i feel like this political
situation that we're in is one of them i
mean it was most certainly one of them
for me personally when i first sued the
trump campaign i had this situation that
faced me and it was like jessica damn it
you need to put your foot down and
handle this for once and for all and i
did and as you know some of the viewers
watching right now have known i was
persistent it was very hard but i was
victorious so right now
we have let these these republicans
these extremists these uh dark money
forces go way way too far for way too
long
let us say thus far and no farther in
these next few months
it is feel like this is it let us just
feel like this is the last chance we
have and we have to lay it all down put
all of our energy i mean write postcards
engage voters i talk to people you know
i talk to people everywhere i talk to
people at gas stations at grocery stores
i mean i just i am very outspoken in the
public be safe you know don't get
yourself in trouble but but don't be
afraid to just engage wherever you are
um i do it all the time and
we can do this we do have the power we
just have to be extremely serious about
it extremely focused and use the next
few months and not squander this
opportunity because it is in your hands
and my hands to determine
to determine our future so let's go
well that's that's great kimberly um i'm
going to give everyone a chance to to do
shameless plugs here but tell us tell us
about tell us about your engagement here
and what what you think uh engagement
sounds like to you because i know lee
had a chance in jessica so what is
engagement to you what does it mean to
you and then give us your shameless plug
i'll go back to jessica and then leave
for the uh for the plugs here
um
well when i was driving
here today thinking about what i was
going to say um
on this podcast i
like emma felt
very helpless and powerless
um and i was trying to think how i could
uh
as an attorney as a female
make the difference here and what i
could do personally to
take the next steps forward it doesn't
help to
be just mad about this to be in my bed
to be upset to
hate the supreme court right now and
politicians and everybody
um i always try
to bring myself back to
what my bosses i work at ben's firm uh
the gyro goes for what ben would say
what my boss mark would say and that's
as an attorney
we're here to be the voices for those
people who can't speak we're here to
fight like hell in a courtroom for
that ultimate
purpose that ultimate goal and i'm very
fortunate that
that is my power and that's what i can
do
and then i was trying to think what
other
people can do who
aren't fortunate enough to have
a stance and can make that position and
to do those things and as
any person
i think this is the most sobering event
to show what happens when we don't vote
when we're not informed
and in california we just had our vote
and i think it was
around 30 percent
i think it was less than that if people
actually voted in our elections
and
this is
the biggest example of what happens when
you don't use the power that you have
and this is what we have
um
so i think
informed voting and for young people in
america in california everywhere
this
is the biggest wake-up call that we need
to be engaged we need to go in
and be informed to gather knowledge um
to gather neutral knowledge from both
sides it's shocking going on two
separate news channels i'll do this
because i just want to see what's the
political agenda of a certain event and
i'll see
the
drastic contrast between each point
between fox and cnn
or msnbc and i try to find
the underlying facts to give an informed
decision for myself and
if i can talk to my friend who then
talks to their friends or their family
and it just the more you speak about it
and base it on facts instead of that
underlying just like keep the passion
that you have in in how this makes you
feel and the rage that you feel but but
really gather the knowledge and the
facts to give those
to make those decisions and so we can
get to the results we want we can have
the actual people in power who will do
something for us
and
i think that's where we need to go with
that
well i appreciate the getting to the
facts because in this day of
misinformation it is tough to sift
through them sometimes um kimberly thank
you for joining us jessica uh let's go
to you i know you um
give us your shameless plug and then
we'll go to lee i know she wants to brag
about her award i want to brag about her
award so
yes i i want i want to brag about your
award this is great you're your
award-winning podcaster so i want to oh
i want to brag about that and jessica
tell us what
some final thoughts and any any plug
that you'd like to make please
all right just picking up what one
kimberly said about about the false
narratives and and lee was talking about
you know
protest you know put your put yourself
out there but don't don't get violent
and and i just want to clarify i mean i
saw at least two things in the last 12
hours about not protesters being violent
but
the counter protesters being violent
against
pro-choice one of them was tear gas
being shot out of the capital windows in
arizona and students
the other one pop just tweeted i
retweeted it about
a i think
candidate democrat candidate in
rhode island being punched by a male
police officer who was actually her
political opponent so let us make sure
that we clear up this narrative um it is
usually the vast majority of of
protesters on
on the pro-choice side are peaceful it
is the it is the anti-choice force birth
movement that has been violent that has
literally killed i mean been after the
lives of abortion workers that has
terrorized these people at their homes i
mean all of a sudden we're all outraged
about people at supreme court justices
homes they actually had a ruling um i
wish we still had the lawyers here to
cite the exact case but they ruled that
it was legal to protest outside of the
homes of abortion workers
so if it's illegal to do that what is
the difference between being outside the
home of the supreme court justice and
i'm not i'm not suggesting anything
violent whatsoever but i'm just let's be
clear about the narrative here and who's
violent and who's peaceful
um
my plug right now is that i i you can
follow me on twitter i have a lot coming
up i don't have any specific things to
give you right now but just stay tuned
there's a lot in the works in my case if
you don't already know i have a pending
class action to invalidate every single
nda that was signed um
in 2016 by any trump campaign staffer
employee or independent contractor
there is a lot going on i have a pending
motion in d.c superior court to hold
steve bannon in contempt for
not showing up for a subpoena in my
original civil lawsuit we're about to
depose some other very high profile
names um lots going on and lots more to
come so stay tuned i'm on twitter at
jessicadenson07 and
thank you to tony thank you to the midas
media network for the wonderful work
you've done and including me in it well
keep us keep us up to date on twitter
about um all your legal cases you know
kicking ass and taking names over there
i definitely i definitely want to hear
about that that that sounds interesting
thank you jessica for joining us lee
what's your final thoughts and give us
give us your plug and please brag about
that award behind you
i'm not bragging about the award tonight
that's not how it works here's the thing
about awards that i think are good if
you get an award because people are
listening and all i'm doing out here is
trying to be a messenger for how people
are feeling in america and what the real
um pulse of the people is because i
think we're all kind of starving to be
heard and to be seen and i think that's
what's happening with these protests
that's what's happening with people's
rage around what's uh around these
decisions is that we need to be out
there demanding to be protected
demanding to be heard demanding to be
seen saying we won't go back we're not
going to go back we won't go and we also
have to have in our heads that failure
is not an option we can't afford to lose
it's just
this is the way it is and i don't think
you should buy into these ideas that the
democrats are doomed because
traditionally in a midterm election
there's nothing happening that's
traditional here there is nothing
happening that is normal and we have to
see what's on the ballot i mean the end
of democracy's on the ballot a woman's
right to her own bodies on the ballot if
we're being quite honest with ourselves
gay rights are on the ballot trans
rights are on the ballot social security
quite frankly is on the ballot
medicare's on the ballot and who makes
decisions for us and who get protected
is on the ballot jessica was just
speaking about
you know the supreme court justices get
protection and you can't be outside of
their houses but you can be outside of
an abortion worker's house
this is not the same we can't have laws
apply to some of us and not to others
and we need to say in our voting and in
our elections this we believe everyone
deserves protection under the law um and
if i was going to plug myself i would
say i am politics girl on twitter um i
am breakfast rant on tick tock and insta
because those are the rants i do in my
kitchen
and the podcast the politics girl
podcast drops every tuesday and i'm
really excited for this week's podcast
because i interviewed and had a candid
conversation with the president of
emily's list lafonza butler on the day
this decision came down and we just had
this
really passionate discussion that i am
so excited to share with people on
tuesday she's just an absolute
powerhouse and if you want somewhere to
put your energy and money right now
emily's list is a great place the
state's project is a great place because
they're focusing on the states and how
we can help at that level and i'm as
always i'm politics girl on youtube so
if you want to watch the podcast
visually um you can watch it on youtube
and if you want to listen you can listen
anywhere you get your pods
thank you very much everyone for joining
us i appreciate your voices um in this
fight
because i think it's important that the
people
hear from the
you know we have so many men sitting
around trying to decide what women are
going to do and what they're not going
to do
with their bodies i think i think george
carlin said it best once you know once
they're willing to implant one of those
uh
embryos into their own bodies maybe then
they can start making decisions for
women but until that tell them maybe
they shouldn't be focused on women's
body bodies maybe they should be focused
on their own so i appreciate
all of you you
intelligent women joining us today for
all your commentary as always thank you
for joining us thank you thank you very
much and come back come back we'll be
with the january 6 hearings as they
return
in july so thank you very much thank you
go listen to politics girl go follow
jessica and be watching kimberly i know
she's going to be litigating these
things in the court she's kicking ass
and taking names so thank you very much
thank you for joining us
bye thank you bye thanks guys
so there you have it we have the uh
coverage of the
roe v wade
protest here in front of the supreme
court we'll bring it up one more time
you see the live coverage here um i i
want i want to say one thing before we
go because uh several
of the great commentators today touched
on the peaceful protest
but they
they also talked about staying calm
and
you have to have strategic outrage that
is super super important here with your
outrage and to be strategic
as you think about the ways that you're
going to engage because you do have the
choice
regardless if if it seems that you don't
you do have the choice these people
right here as you see standing
protesting
in front of the supreme court of the
united states had the choice to go there
that day
today and stand there with those signs
and to protest and you have the choice
to engage you have the choice to have a
conversation you have the choice to
engage in your election
and your government it is a choice that
you can
make so realize
even though they're trying to take away
our rights and that is why you must make
the choice to be engaged you still do
have the choice to be pro-democracy
thanks for joining us here on the midas
media network again
at 8 8 eastern
you will see a special episode of legal
af at the regular time uh having ben my
zealous michael popock
and karen agnipolo who joined us today
thank thank you thank you for joining us
and please uh subscribe to the midas
touch youtube channel for any more
special broadcast and coming up in july
the special
coverage of the january 6 select
hearings uh hit the subscribe button so
you don't miss a thing
thank you for joining us today
you